Lee Jenkins has made the jump from
Sports Illustrated senior NBA writer to
now working for the Clippers and Lee
joins us now to explain the title
executive director of research and
identity it sounds impressive Lee what
the heck does it mean look they're
trying to I think kind of mine a little
bit deeper into who players are and not
just what they do and that kind of
dovetails with what I do what I've done
for Sports Illustrated for a long time
which is really kind of ask who is he
who is he who is he and you know try to
use some different maybe research
gathering techniques like traditional
reporting techniques to you know to kind
of put together the portrait of players
put that puzzle together and I'm excited
about it I don't know exactly how it's
gonna take shape there's me some trial
and error I'm sure but these teams they
want to find different people look at
things look at problems through
different lenses and have different
points of view and hopefully I can bring
that to them okay explain that a little
bit further are you approaching let's
say a draft pick or somebody you might
trade for where you're gonna do a
personality profile as if you were
writing an article in Sports Illustrated
is that yeah yeah Your Honor I don't
know if it's writing an article but it
would what it would be is is sort of cop
finding if you're putting a profile
together of somebody and complimenting
the information they're Scouts already
have their analysts already have so it
would be far more of a team effort than
what I've done but yeah it's kind of
using the techniques you would use to to
put a story together and put kind of the
story together of that player behind the
scenes and and with the people they
already have why the Clippers I think
Tastee Palmer's the only person would
have done this probably who would have
approached you know whose people would
have approached me about it there's a
element to them that seems like the
inevitable underdog it's like every year
I feel like a team wins whether it's the
Royals or the Red Sox or the Cubs are at
the Warriors in the NBA and he said wow
how did that happen I mean that's just
so crazy that Tina had won and so long
just won and and he sort of looked back
to the beginning and it usually starts
with well they
great ownership right and they were in a
lot of times in an alluring market
that's what the Clippers have right off
the bat like they've got the most
committed owner probably and they've got
the most appealing market for NBA
players so you put those two things
together there's a head start and then I
was just able to meet so many so many
people in their front office they are
Lawrence Frank michael winger Trent red
and Mark Hughes all of these people were
so I just got the feeling like this is
inevitable this will happen for them and
this seems like a really good bet you've
done so many deep dives with LeBron
James can you kind of get into his head
as to why he made this decision that he
was going to go to the Lakers are you
trying to get me fine already oh that's
gonna be crazy because I've done nothing
but talk about players for the last
decade and so to me that comes naturally
right so you guys that question and
that's like no one here but I don't know
and that's what's gonna be so awkward
about this is I can't I'll I can't talk
about all that snow is that temporary
about what makes the Clippers the
greatest destination I think it's I
think about frier standings I probably
need to go to tampering 101 and an
iodine it's gonna take a little while I
will for sure get the organization
signed but you can't talk about previous
profiles you've done with LeBron James I
don't I have no idea I mean I mean
either relates to this like I did I did
sort of think about him Allah through
this because it's like he just he makes
so many decisions based on sort of that
sounds fun that sounds different let's
do it go with my friends to Miami win
some championships cool let's do it go
back home create this kind of fairy tale
story do it make a movie create a school
I wish I'd gone to you know so many
things he does you know I thought about
him a little bit with this decision
because I was I was thinking you know
what would what would he think of it I
was I didn't ask you and I just I just
got the sense that it was an opportunity
to sort of keep pushing and learned
something new because I think in our
business I don't know if you feel like
this I feel like I can kind of get close
to truth I can under
stand a little bit of how it feels and
on deadline night or on draft night but
I can't get all the way there I can
never fully understand what that's like
and I think after this I will but you're
also um I'm gonna guess that there's
only so many players you can interview
and in profile but how do you think it's
gonna work are you gonna be more
valuable with the draft for the Clippers
or with free agency I don't really know
how it's gonna go I mean I know that
that there's gonna be I think part of it
is I'm gonna find terrifying my place
where I can help where my skills can
help the most and I think part of what
I'm learning too is like in media and a
lot of Jays it's it's clearly delineated
this is what you're doing but these
organizations are big now and they're a
little bit more corporate and I think
what they want is they want a bunch of
people in the room on a lot of different
things there have already been different
things that I've been talking about that
I never thought would come up at areas
that I didn't think that I could help
but they're like oh yeah we want your
input on this we kind of want to you
know see this from a different side and
so I I don't know how predictable is a
day two days is really gonna be but I
think I'll have fun kind of learning
whatever it is Steve Ballmer always then
thues est now much of it a couple of
times I have yeah I mean it's it's
definitely I mean and really kind of
behind the scenes I mean he can he can
go even more so and I think what it
shows is just it's like if you take
somebody with those resources and you
couple it with that enthusiasm and drive
and I think we all sort of know that
ownership is everything when it comes to
sports that it just it inspires a lot of
confidence I mean he's gonna create an
environment for players and I understand
the history of it I understand the lack
of tradition and I understand that's a
big piece it really is but I still think
if you have the owner and you got the
market and you start to create my dented
efore yourself as a great player
destination that some of those things
can be overcome that the lack of history
can be overcome
good stuff Lee will be watching
hopefully you don't get fine for the
LeBron James topic here I'm sure I will
thanks Dan that's Lee Jenkins for more
Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]